getting started on youtube can sometimes
feel overwhelming with all of the new
things to learn but today i want to
bring to you
our friend rob from vid iq where we're
going to be breaking down some of the
best tools that you should be using
right now as you start and grow your
youtube channel my name is heather
torres and you're watching the youtube
made simple show and we'll get right
into it after this
[Music]
welcome to the youtube made simple show
i am your host heather torres the author
of youtube made simple and i am really
excited to bring my friend rob from vid
iq over here into the think media world
vid iq and think media have been
partnered to help you grow your youtube
channel and vid iq is a tool that i
personally have been using to grow think
media as well as our other youtube
channels because the tools that they
have oh they're so so good they help you
with titles they help you with
thumbnails they help you with
understanding what videos you should be
making and there is no better teacher
than rob to come on this show today to
teach this he is the face of vid iq he's
already a successful youtuber by
building this vid iq channel to over one
million subscribers and i'm excited to
have him on today to be teaching you
three uh different tools that you could
be using on vidiq and stick around to
the end because rob has some bonus
features that he's going to be sharing
with you as well so rob welcome to the
show today
hey everybody hey heather it almost
feels like
we were talking last week about youtube
we were because we were we
were so much fun um well rob uh first
off i'd love just a brief history about
um about vid iq as a company not that
you need to give us the whole outline
but just kind of why vid iq like why
should people be using this tool and
then let's jump into uh those features
that you have
yeah so vidiq as a company i think is
now over a decade old and when um the
co-founders originally started the the
products and the company
their vision was enterprise companies
you know working with red bull no face
uh and big content creators on on
platforms
but there was a very big pivot for the
company i'd say around about six or
seven years ago we went we decided that
we were gonna try and provide all of
these um
tools
for every single creator who wants to
turn their passion into
a career and so we've been um releasing
tools now i think
i think i first started using vidiq back
in 2015 but i think we've been uh been
on the platform youtube now for since
2014 and
the rest is history really we've just
stacked tool on top of tool to the point
where we have
dozens of primary tools probably
hundreds of different
tools set around the
youtube interface and i don't know about
you but whenever i log on to youtube but
not on my own desktop computer youtube
almost looks naked because it doesn't
have any of the vid iq features on there
and thinking hang on why is the video
scorecard not on there oh yeah because
the extension is not installed on this
computer so it should
it's at a point now where i feel is vid
iq is just part of the
the furniture it seamlessly integrates
into into youtube
that is such a great way to describe it
i was just gonna say that i was on a
friend's computer we were on vacation
and i logged in and i was like wait why
did you what happened to youtube and i
was like oh yeah vid iq it i use it so
much rob it's just a part of my everyday
process it's it's a part of how i see
youtube you're right it's kind of it's
in its ecosystem and i'm excited for
people who are maybe new to
understanding these tools um to see the
abundant amount of information that you
can get that can help you reach the
right people and i think that is really
one of the biggest pieces that i love
about having vid iq as a tool in my
toolbox is that it's helping me figure
out the videos that's the biggest part
because youtube wants people to come to
their platform and stay there and keep
watching and vid iq helps you track that
helps you learn what videos to be making
helps you see what's working and what's
not so i'm excited rob for you to dive
into some of the features so i'm going
to hand the floor over to you and i will
bring up your slides when you asked me
to and i'm ready to go yeah thank you um
so
um in terms of what i'm going to show
you to do i i'll show you today i'm
going to show you
first of all some free stuff because hey
everybody likes free tools
and then go into a little bit more
detail of some of the tools that will
help you if you want to invest a little
bit more in a vid iq
um
if you want to share my screen uh now um
i have a thank you but you can stay on
the line heather because i actually have
a little bit of a quiz oh okay both you
and the audience uh to have a bit of fun
with the tools first of all so the
question i'm gonna ask you and all of
our audiences first of all do you know
what is the most watched youtube video
of all time as of today the most watched
youtube video i feel like it has to do
with animals or justin bieber i that
would be my guess so you were you were
correct with the former uh topic yes
the most watched video is
justin bieber
no no no no no it's to do with animals
air bubbles i was like really he's that
popular
if i if i gave you a clue though i would
give it away straight away and i worry i
might copyright claim
this live stream
uh so think of something that's uh very
popular with children they sing it all
of the time
you are indeed correct and the final
question is
do you know how many views it has i
would say it's gotta be over a billion
views i mean
that's i mean i know kids that watch
baby shark like at least 100 times a day
so you're close but also miles away
because it is as of now
10
billion views
that's effectively every single human
being on the planet watching it at least
once or as you say heather uh children
all across the world watching it a
thousand times a day
now the reason i'm asking you this is
because of this new analytic that we
have
that we recently introduced which tells
you
that not only does the video have 10
billion views it's also 5 years old but
here's the incredible thing
right now
this hour is getting 191
000 views per hour on a five-year-old
video
uh which is a children's song which is
astonishing i can't quite get my head
around that that is a a phenomenal
number
and that's what we're looking at as our
first tool which is views per hour and
it's kind of like a secret hidden number
on content which tells you
what content is trending right now
irrespective of whether it was launched
and so we've had a bit of fun here in
terms of you know just really popular
videos getting views but there are many
practical purposes for this uh i did i
did a search before we went live on best
camera for youtube and
would you believe it
think media as at the top of the search
rankings as you would expect
but here's a really interesting thing
with the numbers behind what we're
seeing here
the top video from think media gets 75
views per hour which if you average that
out over a period of a day is
what two
over 1500 views 2 000 views a day that's
pretty impressive that's approaching ten
thousand views uh no more than ten
thousand views per week but what i find
interesting here is how the competing
videos just don't seem to really have a
chance
eight views per hour nine views per hour
so this top think media video is
absolutely crushing it in this area of
youtube search and then if we scroll
down a list again think media 21 views
per hour uh another one here 19 views
per hour
so it seems clear to me that think media
has a very tight grip on this topic
which means that as a creator
i may be steering clear of this specific
search term
whereas for you heather and think media
you may be thinking we really know how
to dominate this search term we'll
probably make
probably another a video on this in two
months like the best cameras for the
second half of 20 2010 to for youtube
beginners so it's starting to give me a
little bit of an in the scenes here
on the home page you get some really
interesting facts about views per hour
as well
we'll take this top example here of a
video from yes theory which is an
intriguing video about living with
wolves for 72 hours wow i don't
necessarily have an interest in this
channel or this topic
but because this video is so popular on
youtube it's got 1.5 million views two
and a half thousand views per hour
youtube is recommending that to me right
now
but then we also have a video here from
creator insider which is 28 minutes old
and is only getting 75 views per hour so
why is why is that managed to
muscle its way onto my home page and the
answer is that is personalization
not only is youtube taking into account
what's popular
on the youtube platform but taking into
account my personal viewing habits and
it knows that whenever creator insider
poster video or nate from channel makers
or indeed think media i'm likely to
watch it
even though it has much less popularity
on youtube
so the understanding here is that if
youtube understands your content and
which audience to serve it to it will
always give your video a chance even if
it's getting a lot less views per hour
and another really fascinating thing i
found here as i was scrolling down uh
these videos
i don't know about you but i've started
to see a lot of old batman videos on
youtube such as this one like this is
from 11 from two years ago
it has 11 million views but it's getting
200 nearly 3 000 views per hour right
now and again the question might be why
is that and the answer is there's been a
new batman video that's just been
released and if i go into the video in
more detail this is the actual watch
page
over on the right hand side here we have
a tool which allows you to look at the
historical data of a video by clicking
on this graph here
and look what's happened to this video
as the new batman's batman movie has
been released
youtubers recognize that viewers are
searching for batman content be it old
or new and this video has suddenly shot
up in terms of views per hour so it's
pushing
old but relevant content to me and i
find that absolutely fascinating
uh we had a question come in rob does
this function
come with the free version of it iq or
are you into the paid versions so what i
can tell you is that um when you see
this count views per hour on the home
page search pages
channel pages suggested views
um
that is all free
but when we get to something in a little
more detail such as this tool uh the the
historical graph then that is a paid
version of our tools
amazing and you know one thing that i
always recommend for content creators um
is is do what you can to invest in the
areas that really matter if i had to
choose between
you know uh upgrading gear on when i
already have the gear versus purchasing
something like this tool i actually lean
towards purchasing the tool versus
upgrading the gear because these tools
will help you just create better content
with what you already have so if you're
not already invested in vid iq i'll tell
you a little bit more about how you can
get a uh 30 days free but rob keep going
this is fascinating already
so a little bit more on views per hour
is that we can take this to a channel
level and again apologies however i'm
using think media as a bit of a guinea
pig here but um
usually you would look at a channel and
you would sort by most popular and that
might give you an indication of um the
videos have been popular on the channel
in its history
you know this one about the cheapest
camera on amazon seven and a half
million views best editing tips three
and a half million views all brilliant
but again vidiq has a secret weapon here
this button called trending what this is
going to do is divide up the videos by
which you're getting the most views per
hour now
and i can see
that think media has a little bit of a
niche here of providing funny sound
effects and i can see that you've
revisited this topic a couple of times
heavy you did that one like two years
ago which got two million views yep you
did another one nine months ago no that
got two million views and then another
one recently with a hundred thousand
views but look at the views per hour
that's the type of content that's going
to keep paying itself for months if not
years to come and if i was doing
research on your channel and i was
thinking like what maybe i could um do
vid iq if i thought it was a related
content i would be looking at
free
free um
stuff to give away to viewers whether it
be free thumbnail templates
sound design and so on
and i actually did this very recently
with nate from channel makers i'm sure
many of you have heard of nate from
channel makers he's another youtube
educator yep uh now he has just launched
a video 10 hours ago so as you can see
that's obviously got the most views per
hour because it's very recent the
velocity on that is high it's been sent
out to subscribers it's appearing on
home pages and so on
but this video did take my interest and
it was made four months ago
if i was starting a youtube channel in
2022 and it's got half a million views
and crucially
months after it was published it's still
getting a decent number of views per
hour
so i decided uh about three months ago
that i was going to
um
take inspiration from this idea
and remake the video in my own
um interpretation
and we did that a couple of months ago
and this was a result for us
similar title
obviously redoing a video my own
style and tips and tricks and this one
got a quarter of a million views and
that's getting 50 views per hour so not
quite as popular as nate's video but
just that bit of research gave me the
the impetus to make this video and
you know this video is doing absolutely
fine we're very happy with it
so this is just an insight into
views per hour and how it can help you
understand what's trending not only for
fun you know in terms of baby shark but
also in terms of content creation
and with that too rob one of the things
that can happen when you take
inspiration from other channels that are
in the similar niche is you um is that
you can get picked up and suggested
because youtube if says okay if they
already watched this video they probably
also want to watch rob's video so it
gives different um opportunities for
your videos to show up like other videos
and we do this a lot actually not to
tell you rob but i have that same exact
video coming out in just a couple weeks
because i saw the same exact thing and i
think what's so great is we can learn
from each other and and here's the big
thing when it comes to looking at
competition like that i don't actually
see it as competition i'm like we all
get to help people we get to help and
serve this community and i'm fine if
they want to watch think media and vid
iq and channel maker's version of it
because i want people to succeed um but
there is something great about making
videos that you're inspired by with
people in your same niche that can help
get your videos into the suggested and
maybe you become their favorite person
we have people that only love nolan on
our channel we have people that only
love heather on our channel there's
people that only love rob and that's
totally fine when it comes to that but
it's really cool to see that we can take
inspiration from each other like that by
the features that vid iq is offering
yeah the term i like to use is a passive
collaboration yeah when you're when
you're researching other people's
content and then remodeling it in your
own style and just going to this video
if i started a youtube channel in 2022
you can see down the the watch
the suggested videos here you can see
all the views per hour and bang that
original nate video is connected to our
content as well along with think media
stuff and and ed from film booth and
roberto blake so we're all kind of in
this network
working together kind of secretly and
not directly
but ultimately if the viewer is getting
the value that they need
uh then
hopefully we all
you know i i've had this a phrase before
the tide rises for all boats and we all
we all benefit from that
so that was views per hour as as we were
saying however the majority of the tools
here are free
but the historical detail of a video
this tool is a paid tool and also the
trending button here would be a paid
tool i think you get like three other
videos not the entire list uh for views
per hour
but certainly a lot certainly this as
you were saying like this is one of
these where where
youtube doesn't look right without this
this detail of views per hour and that's
that's what we decided to introduce once
youtube removes public dislikes and we
couldn't give um
ratings for videos we decided to replace
it with something really valuable for
creators
yes i i love that that is an option and
actually it caught my eye when it
changed i was like oh this is a fun new
tool because you can actually see how
popular that video is and know if you
should recreate it or if you should be
inspired by it or if it's even something
you want to watch because
social proof also matters there's videos
sometimes rob i'll see that and i'm like
oh only three people okay well i
probably don't want to watch that but if
there's one with 35 people uh or views
per hour i want to watch that one so it
even helps with uh how how social
proofed your um meaning just how many
people are actually wanting to watch
that video and if you're the creator rob
some of the takeaways i would have from
that too is if your views per hour are
really low you may need to pivot your
video you may need to pivot the title or
pivot the thumbnail it gives you those
clarity points of understanding if like
you've been doing really really well and
then you switch something that could be
an indicator of change that may need to
happen on your channel
yeah absolutely absolutely
well awesome what's the next tool rob
yeah so let's move on to a another tool
that we very recently um released and we
are pretty excited about this one
because it's already had
some positive impacts on the content
that we've been making when i first when
i use this tool for the first time i got
the golden 1 of 10
on that video which just made me very
happy um for this tool and it is called
if i can find it on the right screen yes
it is the title
uh recommendation tool
and what this essentially does is take
keywords
or just uh an inkling of an idea and
turns it into
an exciting title that is
hopefully more clickable
than the title you were struggling with
or the idea that you'd come up with this
tool is going to appear
when you upload a video
or when you are editing a video after
it's been uploaded and you can see the
button right here get ai title
recommendation
so
let's use um one of the titles that we
or one of the ideas that we previously
searched for and i'm going to look at
best camera and what this is going to do
is start to generate some headlines that
are going to be
not only
the impetus for a more specific video
idea but also a title that may be
clickable so i'll click
generate some titles
and already
we're having some interesting
suggestions here the best camera for
photographers so that's defining your a
target niche phrasing it as a question
how to choose the best camera for you or
doing it as a listicle five of the best
cameras
for beginners and professionals so again
you you're really looking at the um
target audience here or best camera for
your new smartphone and that's an
interesting one i presume that's maybe
adding some
special lenses to your smartphone if
none of these titles are suitable you
simply click refresh and you get another
collection of
ideas some of them may not be what you
want like the 10 best cameras of 2018
all right you can change that to very
simply 20 22 as opposed to 2018 and then
you're going to be getting a better
solution and then another one here best
camera for 2018 getting changed up to
2022 but then a qualifying question
which one is better and that might
influence
how you build your thumbnail you might
have two cameras uh almost facing off
against each other with a big versus uh
icon that's kind of an imagery that's
coming up from in my head from this uh
title
i
am obsessed with this tool rob i love
this tool so much because i've spent a
lot of time uh studying titles studying
the idea of you know how do you how do
you craft the best title that people
want to click on and this has basically
allowed my brain to not have to go to
those depths anymore and here's what i
do i get so geeked out on this tool that
i'm like screenshotting i should have
pulled it up i have like screenshots of
other videos i want to make because i'm
like oh that's a good title it's not
right for this video but that's a great
title and then i go down this rabbit
hole of being able to do that but this
has cut down so much time for me
personally on trying to figure out the
best title so i love that you start with
as a title that you're thinking of and
then it generates those other ideas for
you now what plan is this one on rob is
it the boost or the pro to be able to
have that feature so again i i believe
you get uh some free suggestions i think
it's three um refreshes per month
and then you're moving into the pro and
the boost uh options to get more
suggestions obviously on the boost tool
you're gonna get unlimited so i can
click refresh as many times as i want
and i'm gonna get um title suggestions
uh like why you need 100 youtube
subscribers to be successful that could
be an indication of what what tools do
you unlock at 100 subscribers how do you
get 1000 subscribers from one video in
one week all right it's not about 100
subscribers but that's a really
interesting way of
qualifying the goal and making it
achievable really interesting stuff
there
i love that i actually uh we have a
student inside a video ranking academy
in 10 days he was able to get a thousand
subscribers i'm stealing that title rob
i'm gonna do that title so good i love
it
yeah a house mortgage i thought this was
some really fantastic suggestions for
any real estate um
creators the american dream house
mortgage or is it possible to own a
house without a mortgage how to buy a
house with only a small down payment
these are all like the pivotal questions
that people are asking uh when they're
when they're buying the the home the
first home or the second home or trying
to buy a home with a bad credit
all i have to do is press refresh and i
get another five ideas and i keep
pressing refresh
so this is a fantastic tool the the one
i used it for
was
youtube mistakes
that was my idea and the title that it
came up with um which was just
so cool that we ended up using it
uh it was this
so from youtube mistakes we got this
title
five mistakes that send your youtube
channel to hell and like that just
summed up everything
that i was trying to to get from from
the the messaging in the um the video
and that really helped me decide the um
thumbnail as well
and the analytics prove it prove here
that it is performing
above average for our channel so
great validation there excellent watch
time very happy with it all really
really awesome yeah tutorial mag says
great tool um
uh christian explained uh i'm on the pro
plan uh it works best it works perfect
with daily ideas so that's exciting too
yep that's coming up
and that is i think one of the best um
why i love to even just share vid iq
with every creator i know is because
it's doing the thinking for you like
it's taking away those pieces and look
at the results that are already
happening um i did show that if you
wanted to get 30 days free of what rob
is talking about some of these tools you
could do that at vidiq.com forward slash
think we're in partnership with vidiq
and so you can get 30 days free um to
try out these tools and see if they are
right for you so what is the next tool
we should look at rob
yeah i was just going to add a one final
point on the um
title generator is that as you say
heather it does the thinking for you so
it's actually better to almost give it
less detail uh rather than writing in a
full title because it's kind of hard to
extrapolate new ideas from a from a
already formed title just type in like
two or three words uh that i are your
four more concept and that's what's
going to generate the titles so that is
the secret hack then rob you just saw
yeah yeah you would type in like you
said home mortgage or best camera and
then it will do more of the work for you
pulling the titles that could really be
the best ones absolutely absolutely so
yes somebody hinted at our next tool
which is daily ideas
this is the type of tool you should be
um using
if you are struggling to come up with uh
new content on your channel or that is
something that is typically hard for you
uh coming up with your next video idea
this i would say is more of a broad
scope tool than the title generator in
that it's designed for volume it's not
necessarily going to give you a perfect
idea every single time but if it is
suggesting similar ideas
throughout its suggestions then you'll
start to pick up p themes and patterns
because on the boost plan you get
up to 50 video ideas every single day
which quick maths is at least over a
thousand video ideas every single month
and if you're creating
two videos a week
then you're probably covered for video
ideas
there's two ways to use this tool you
can even use it as almost like a tinder
card where you're swiping left or
swiping right or in this case saving or
dismissing uh so if you save something
it's going to save it up to our list in
the top left here and if i dismiss
something then it just puts it in the
discard pile but you can check each of
these lists
to reference what you've saved
previously or look at
stuff that you um have
you have saved and want to do a bit more
research on
you can also click onto the card at the
list view so now i'm seeing all 50 ideas
uh from today's suggestions
and as you can see as a youtube
education channel we're getting
generally suggestions on how to earn
more money on youtube or are there any
new algorithms on youtube people want to
grow their channels faster how to
promote your content on youtube so these
are all
ideas at this point i may not
necessarily use these as titles for my
videos although some of them aren't bad
but i would be getting a lot of um
innovation and creative juices flowing
from
these tools and all i have to do on
either of these
ideas is click
to drill down into what is happening on
youtube in terms of this content so
how to promote your content on youtube
is giving me suggestions from other
youtube educators and i knew i would
find nolan somewhere on this list there
he is and it's almost as if nolan used
our title generator
for his video like five ways to promote
your youtube um videos to get more views
seems like a really
seo strong title that one
yeah nolan is a student of vid iq and uh
and definitely uses this tool and that
title generator tool um so yes this is a
great one and then the thumbnails look
at these thumbnails they're so um
vibrant and each one of these videos is
so good look at same thumbnail
there is a famous in there created on
the right hand side with expression uh
text or detail or i always prefer
numbers when we're talking about youtube
i prefer numbers green arrows growth
that type of thing i think nolan's uh
nailed it there yeah
i love this tool um and daily ideas uh
you can get that um which one of the
different plans
so on the free plan you get uh three
daily ideas a day so you're still
getting uh what up to a hundred per
month on the pro planet's 10 and then
for boost it's 50 ideas a day and so
hopefully more than enough um
suggestions every single
um every single day really and this is
where you can type back into the title
generator a tool that we looked at
previously so again if i just go back to
my
draft video so i don't edit any of my
current videos
let's try promote
youtube
it was bringing some really interesting
results uh yesterday when i was testing
this
five ways to promote your youtube videos
how to promote your youtube channel uh
all solid suggestions there
the ultimate youtube promotion strategy
oh that's an interesting one
10 minutes to learn how to promote your
youtube videos
i like videos
that's probably the one i'd use
promote you promote youtube like a boss
promote your channel like a boss
something along those lines
um so yeah again fans
so you know stage one idea ideation
get suggestions next step put it into
the title generator
and there you have really that the
the very beginning of how you may want
to plan a youtube video
really really smart all right so we've
learned now three of the different
ones rob um i want to let people know
that if they want to
get access to any of these tools um you
can do that by going to vidiq.com
forward slash think we had someone ask
if this will be on replay because this
video is already filled with so much
value yes this will be on replay for you
and you can come back and watch it at
any time here on the show but rob what
is the next
bonus tool that we have
yeah so
um
obviously
youtube is not just about
creating
it's about celebrating your achievements
and giving yourself a little pat on the
back uh when you have reached certain
milestones and this tool is completely
free for everybody
and it is our achievements tool
so on the desktop screen you're going to
see lots of tools from us but down the
left hand side we have
lots of different tools from vidiq and
one of them is achievements and if you
click on that
it's going to tell you a little more
than milestones such as 100 000
subscribers a million subscribers it's
gonna
show you achievements based on views
likes hours watched how many comments
you've got like when was the last
achievement we hit the last achievement
we hit was 85 million views wow on our
youtube channel uh which we achieved
just under a month ago and it's telling
us our progress to the next milestone
which should hopefully
happen around about the beginning of may
and where we currently are and if i
wanted to share that i can click that
button and on the fly vid iq will
generate a certificate which then you
can share with your community be on
twitter instagram the youtube community
tab uh or you can frame it i've i've
framed about 10 of these going from 100
000 subscribers to a million i have all
of them uh somewhere and it keeps the
date as well which is really helpful to
tell me uh when we hit all of those
milestones and so yeah this is just a
nice little freebie uh to recognize your
hard work
as a content creator and that
you are allowed to spend a minute or two
basking in your own glory of
achievements before you start work on
the on the next
video
i love this and where do you find this
tool specifically do you need a log into
uh vid iq
like the website or you can find it
right on youtube so once you've
authenticated your youtube channel uh
with vid iq which of course we highly
recommend you do to get many of these
tools such as daily ideas uh just down
this left hand navigation bar we have
the achievements tool right there and it
will bring it up
so so awesome and what i think is so
amazing about this inside of our um
video ranking academy we do milestone
mondays and because we've shown people
how to find this tool it's so fun that
we'll have you know 400 500 vid iq
stickers on there of different
achievements of views and watch hour and
subscribers and it's just a great way to
celebrate and you know you see those big
numbers rob that you guys that bit iq is
already pulling up we're pulling up big
numbers but we all started from zero
right we did indeed this is not um an
overnight thing but what is so great is
to be able to see these milestones
happening right it's it's 10 subscribers
and then 100 subscribers and then a
thousand subscribers and then into a
million subscribers as you keep
producing great content and so i think
it's really great um i would suggest
that at least once a month you go and
just look at your achievements because
sometimes growth can seem very small but
when you can look at the overall picture
of what's happening you can really see
that the progress that you're making the
videos you're putting out the work
you're putting in is
actually giving you great results so i
love the achievements and i'm so glad
that you brought that up rob because a
lot of times we're so critical about you
know what does this thing look like or
how did this thing do or let's look at
the analytics but one of the analytics
you should be looking at is the
achievements that you're creating with
this and i think it's such a great
fabulous tool that vidiq's put together
i should also mention as well i believe
that um we will email you
certain milestones i don't think we send
all of them because i've stuff like um
uploads likes comments you probably
don't want to be notified of them but
it's still interesting achievements to
look at so yeah i handwrite every single
email
that celebrates your achievements i
really do i honestly really do i i i
dedicate eight hours a night preparing
all of those emails for our two million
plus users
i definitely see that wrong
i definitely see that that is what you
did
wouldn't that be funny though
just know that rob is here
congratulating you every time you
receive one of those emails that happens
well rob do we have any more tools we
want to share with the creator community
today
i think uh given that we've shown what
four tools there that's probably enough
to digest i mean as we've said we
it's hard to count how many tools we
have now but if i just reeled off like
keyword inspector the most vue tool
channel audits
the list is endless at this point so
i think one of the daunting things about
vid iq is once you install it it's like
whoa
that's a lot of information
so
just
download the extension
get familiar with it and then take
advantage of the offers uh that think
media has to get really into the nitty
gritty of what we have to offer yeah and
rob yeah i think vid iq um one of the
things also is that they teach you how
to use the tools you are teaching how to
use the tools here on think media and
over on your channel um but where can
they go if they want to learn they get
all these tools like you said and it can
be overwhelming when this is brand new
when you're just starting out on youtube
you now download it you authenticate it
and then all of a sudden all these new
numbers come up what would you suggest
for someone who's just starting out what
should they do first so we do have a
playlist on our channel uh which will uh
take you through uh i think all of the
tools i think i'm trying to find which
one is here so
just a little way down our
channel page we have uh this
playlist which will take you through all
of the tools we also have a vidiq
academy
where we have like a 40-minute
introduction to how to best use or why
you should use some of our vid iq tools
and of course we have uh all of the
support on
the vid iq website and you can just
email us we're happy to give you
specific help for your vid iq needs uh
via our awesome customer service team
who are available
24 7 in english i'm not sure we support
several languages but definitely 24 7 in
english oh we'll certainly get an answer
back to you within within a few hours
so awesome well thank you so much rob
for being on the show today sharing
those tools with us i'm sure you'll be
back next week because we seem to be
doing this now weekly
it's been really fun to have you on um
thank you so much and i'd love to know
what your aha moment was from today's
show was it that you can now figure out
how to do your titles and you don't have
to think about it was it that you can
celebrate your achievement was it seeing
how many views per hour are actually
happening on your videos and your
competitors videos i would love to know
what your aha moment was down in the
comment section below and just a
reminder to let you know that we are
just weeks away from one of the biggest
number one uh video marketing
conferences that is happening here in
las vegas may 2022 we've got grow with
video live in just a few short weeks so
if you want to join us and vid iq in
person for the number one conference for
entrepreneurs who want to learn how to
grow their personal brand using videos
then you definitely want to make it to
this event so thank you so much for
watching let me know in the comment
section below if you got value out of
today's video and we'll catch you next
time
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please be on your
feet welcome to the stage
give it up for gary
vaynerchuk
i am tired of people not starting and
living their life on one very simple
thing which is they're worried about
what other people think
regardless of what you're trying to
accomplish you've got to tell the world
about it this is now the world if you're
not betting on this you're finished if
you're not betting on this you're
finished if you're not bending on this
you're finished